hallo leute willkommen zu blocken estag
nummer 14 ich kann sie jetzt
mittlerweile leider nicht mit meinen
händen machen ist vielleicht auch nicht
schlimm da ich mich immer da ich das
letzte
ich habe mir meine messie wohnung
aufräumen video gefallen hat mache ich
das heute noch mal und zwar braucht mein
arbeitszimmer und mein badezimmer eine
komplette reinigung
einerseits weil es da aussieht als würde
wirklich eine bombe eingeschlagen und
zweitens weil heute meine beste freundin
aus kiel kommt das ganze wochenende an
ii
du kennst die annina du magst diani wir
mögen anni ja meine haut die sagte
görner deswegen probieren wir heute
diese maske aus die waren dem
adventskalender von amazon made in
germany für reife haut ich habe mich
schon wollen gefragt habe ich reifer
haut ich bin mir nicht sicher ich glaube
ich habe schon eine sehr erwachsene haut
jetzt mittlerweile ich zitiere
offizieren ich muss nicht viel extra
fußgeruch ins bad gehen warum ich auch
dass eine gesichtsmaske brauche ist weil
ich ziemliche sorgenfalten in meinem
gesicht heute bekommen hab ich glaube
ich kann sogar die sorgenfalten für
heute noch sehen seht ihr das da sind
die sorgenfalten das sind die
sorgenfalten hier
das sind alles sorgen zweiten ich habe
sorgen weil ich heute die
steuererklärung abrechnung für 2018
bekommen habe ich habe dich schon
ewigkeiten abgegeben und ein
steuerberater und ich waren da schon
ewig hinterher aber irgendwie das
finanzamt ist nicht zu potte gekommen
und hat das nicht bearbeitet und jetzt
ist es soweit und lasst mich euch sagen
2018 you got me geht also jetzt verstehe
ich warum manche youtuber pleitegehen es
ist nämlich so dass ich geld auf meinem
konto habe und immer wusste dass etwas
davon mir gehört aber ich natürlich noch
steuern abgeben muss ich glaube in
deutschland sind das so 40 prozent oder
keine
ahnung also auf jeden fall der grund
warum ausgewandert ist und als ich heute
diese steuerabrechnung gesehen habe habe
ich mich nicht gewundert dass um
ausgewandert ist
ich habe zum glück genug geld
zurückgelegt aber das auf so einem also
es ist so viel es ist so viel geld und
bevor wir heute die große putzaktion
staaten wollen wir noch mittagessen
gehen und zwar weil wir ein neues rahmen
restaurant ausprobieren ich glaube es
ist nicht neu aber für uns ist es neu
und deswegen ich sehe jetzt super fresh
aus denn wir müssen noch für montag ein
instagram foto machen worauf ich mich
frei und ich hoffe das wird cool
aussehen weil ich hab mich extrem schick
angezogen er kannst du dich auf meiner
community mal zeigen was nutzt mir dann
läufern wenn ich ihn gar nicht zeigen
kann hallo du bist nur ach mein freund
ist so toll
er macht einfach die wäsche weil wir
eine ausgeglichene beziehung haben wir
lieben uns richtig doll oder klicks
kriegsmann die kriegs klicks klicks
bevor wir zum restaurant gehen mache ich
jetzt meine adventskalender natürlichen
auf teamarbeit schon aufgemacht und weil
hier war da ist immer was du so denkst
was ich gerne haben wollen würde
[Musik]
nein nicht dein ernst also das universum
wir gehen einfach ja ja und sorry ich
weiß ich bin manchmal so viel zu sehr
hohe energie bürger aber das ist
mittlerweile echt seltsam und die
bewusstseins gerade passiert auf gut ist
noch was drin so gut zeichnen wie du
kann ich nicht darum wird das hier nur
ein gedicht heute genießt du keine
sterneküche doch morgen abend entführt
dich zum märchenhütte immer sagt mir das
kannst du das nachträglich eingeführt
ist das machen dürfen so etwas ändern
aber warum gibt es tickets rechnete
märchenhütte aber animonda als vorspeise
hatte ich tun für schnee geary und timo
takita die akura welchen
die mit dem oktopus ein bisschen links
drauf der live-ticker laden sagen
das gut
hatte gespannt wir haben das auch mal
schön
das ganze welchen haben
ist gut
absolute hat der mauer qualität
und dass sachsen
[Musik]
betroffen sind nach dem christmas trees
die holleins ist das rauchen ist schön
ich mir diesen heißen sich alles nochmal
ist kein so sei es nicht
das war echt weiter ich habe mir noch
extra
youtube-videos lange zu leben und kommt
14 namen machen und dann kurz ist mit so
einer nicht verkürzen ist mit einer
mächtigen
ist auch nicht drin hier sieht man
welche heute nochmals das war schon mal
besser nicht
das sieht auch kollegin diana war
was darf bei dem kurzen verschnaufen das
richtige und nämlich kein mais habe ich
bei mir drin meint wenn ich nur die
einzige devise von 14 alle auf 104
professor rahmen professor der nudel
test
was ich sehr gut finde ist dass hier
sie haben unseren standard rahmen laden
gefunden
hammer endlich hat die suche ein ende
über noch nie mit einem rahmendaten
richtig zufrieden deswegen das ist china
fleisch
auch muss hoch als dass wir in berlin
immer wieder eine empfehlung wert oder
wie hat es ihnen gefallen
du brauchst zum ersten mal glaube war
immer wieder eine empfehlung wert ich
war da schon einmal aber ist extremst
rast über lecker als dankeschön das
findet nämlich auch das war wirklich
also leute hier auf dem mercedes platz
ist es shibuya geht da bitte hin weil
ich schon wieder verlustängste haben
glaube dass dieser laden einfach bei zu
macht weil dieser mercedes platz safety
ja die ganzen anderen lehnen die jungen
mich hier nicht hegen da ist toni war es
egal dass viele leute hashtag selbst
wenn ihr armen essen gehen wollte oder
lecker dazu später hin
hallo ich mache werbung kommt die kunst
des zeichnens folgt mich heute als
standard einmal hierhin legen und wieder
gehen
tschüss witzig wenn sie jetzt signiert
während ich es gar nicht geht ist das
ein perfektes weihnachtsgeschenk oder
was ich hab gedacht das ist eine gute
investition wäre willkommen beim einem
sandhaufen also arbeitszimmer also
ehemalig arbeitszimmer jetzt mein
atelier schrägstrich gästezimmer viel
haben sich gewundert weil sie ein
zweites bett gesehen haben und dann
nicht ganz genau wussten ob timo und ich
schlafzimmer teilen
das ist mein altes bett was ich in das
arbeitszimmer gesteckt habe damit meine
gäste den besten komforth haben
ich wollte am anfang fällt auch eine
couch erstellen die man zu einem bett
machen kann aber ich habe gedacht wenn
gäste kommen das ist mit keine matratze
daten über bed drauf und es ist einfach
sehr sehr gemütlich aber weil mein
schreibtisch irrt nicht mit drin steht
ja habe ich die wissen wollten wie
ignoriert
anni kommt in drei stunden und das kann
ich ihr nicht als es ihr gästezimmer
anbieten
die frau muss extra aus kiel
ein bisschen langer weg ich möchte ihr
das beste bieten
und weil ihr so euch gefreut haben über
das messie aufräumen video dachte ich
komm wir machen das noch mal mit meinem
gästezimmer arbeitszimmer protokoll ich
glaube ich jetzt einfach atelier von
atelier klingt einfach am putzen da
können uns alle einig sein und mit
soviel samen in meinem bauch
wir machen ein kleines vorher nachher
oder hier sehen sie ecke nummer eins wir
haben einen drucker eine kiste mit kram
kartons ecke nummer zwei hier ist meine
monster dahin gewandert ich glaube sie
fühlt sich hier noch nicht ganz so wohl
ich habe aber auch seitdem aufgehört mit
ihr zu sprechen vielleicht muss ich das
einmal nachholen so jetzt können wir
aber zum horror warum ich wirklich
durchdrehe nicht sogar oma oh hab ich
euch das bett gezeigt genauso sollte ein
einladendes bett aussehen lassen wir auf
raten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
musri präsenten als mr video
naturwerkstatt wird das nicht passieren
staub ist gewicht gesaugt wurde auch das
sieht gut aus bis hin vieles da oben
drauf ich muss mir überlegen alles
sortiert vor allem ein ganzer bastl kram
jetzt kommen wir zu dieser ecke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fertig
[Musik]
welt ist neu bezogen diesen traumfänger
und die schlechten träume zu fangen das
regal das sieht auch wieder aufgeräumt
bücher halbwegs farblich sortiert kommen
wir jetzt nun wirklich zum raum of shame
mein badezimmer
also das war mal aufgeräumt ja ja ja ich
glaube das wird jetzt so schön aussehen
im schnelldurchlauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier doch was könnte ich allen die ein
kleines geschenk machen weil sie ich bin
happy
das ist doch schön oder das stelle ich
jetzt neben ihr bett und das ist ein
willkommensgeschenk
[Musik]
oh mein gott drei stunden später
hertel und meine haare so komisch aus
mittlerweile ja das ist ich zeige euch
das jetzt mal nach war alles sauber ist
das essen um mein gott so dass wir die
schale
[Musik]
darauf machen die bekannten machte dass
wir wollen berlin und wuppertal
die eingestellt
seetang salat
alles vegan
und dann blinkt
[Musik]
von aubergine
die qualität ist gut ist das okay das
ist in den boxen
ja ich guck das ja auf meinem pc dh
definiert und er sieht gut aus
ja die hat aber auch oliver otto der
4300 das kleine ding du hast jetzt hier
gerade handelst du die ganze zeit auf
[Gelächter]
also es ist vier uhr morgens mehr
beflogen
ich bin im internet gibt es einmal
schwenke auf den schwingen
[Gelächter]
lasst uns alle zusammen den arm beenden
also wir hoffen ihr hattet spaß haben
wir immer wie gefällt dir ein sauberes
zimmer an die wundervoll
es ist fantastisch was trinkst du dir
jetzt brause edel trans es ist vier uhr
morgens leute wir waren jetzt in der
bahn berlin haben uns auch ein bisschen
verquatscht sag ich mal
[Gelächter]
[Musik]